Jaakko how can I encourage a sense of
urgency this is a hard one and in others
yeah well yeah I think I'm assuming that
this means with others but for either
yourself or others what you have to
realize is that time is going by very
fast and when you have projects that are
due the minute you look at them you
gotta say this is gonna take longer than
we think it's gonna take let's start
moving on it now and then set yourself
really tight timelines to make things
happen and that what that'll do is will
make you realize how far behind the
power curve you are that wasn't one of
my rules when I was in the SEAL Teams
was I was always saying let's be as far
ahead to the power curve as power as
possible as we possibly can so is that a
normal expression power curve like
that's the thing that you're trying to
stay ahead of because it's gonna smash
you so I would always you know just we
didn't slow down the power curve if we
got we thought we were ahead go ahead
further but I I always had a really good
sense that that power curve was coming
to crush us huh so that's what you have
to do get as far ahead of it as you can
tell everyone where it is I've set some
small goals say oh you don't think this
is gonna this projects gonna take long
okay cool
let's just finish this first six percent
which means this this and this and let's
have that done by tomorrow afternoon
tomorrow afternoon comes in they're not
even close okay guess what we need to
align we need to get a sense of urgency
going so we can get this done that's it
I know that to encourage a sense of
urgency in yourself what you can do kind
of works sometimes is you think about
the feeling you're gonna have after it's
done and then consider things that you
already did get done you're have those
things well you're different but
sometimes we the people have things that
man we need to do and it's just a small
thing you know and like I'll do it I'll
do it later I'm doing something right
now do it I know tomorrow yeah sure
that's pretty intuitive to you but you
know sometimes you just be like doing it
later we're just gonna do it later
because I'm thinking about something
right now or I'm doing something right
now and then do it now or while you're
thinking about doing it you just do it I
know yes I don't think you're under your
kids all the time hey do the
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah you'd already be done I know that's
the thing that's the whole point right
there so when you do it when you do the
thing let's say you got a whatever you
gonna respond to an email
I don't know and after you do it that
just that feeling right when it's done
you're like dang not that a that what
didn't take much a that's not gonna be
case every time but didn't take much em
beat I'm done mmm my daddy said this
saying is what he'd say do it and it'll
be done that's a good saying and as a
kid I was like oh that's like it is what
it is yeah I know it is what it is you
said that you don't have to say that you
know but what's your dad's first name
technically it's William Charles Jr okay
well those like BC we have a new quote
from BC PCO for Bill Charles Charles
yeah yeah so BC is in the house you know
do it and it is done I like that one do
it and it'll be done do it and it will
be done yeah I changed it a little bit
do it and it's done yeah same thing
same idea but his thing was always yeah
exactly the same thing earth and the
exact words BC do it and it'll be done
yeah at me as a grown adult arguably
your parent words and now I'm seeing the
genius of it you know doing it'll be
done like you don't have to save it